hey guys merry here with gamespot
presenting the mix at GDC 2016 I'm here
with Lee vermeulen you're from alien
trap yep and you're gonna be show me you
guys make so many games all the time I
almost can't keep up with you guys you
guys I swear you like just I was just
playing crypt dark but now you're
showing maximum maximum override yeah we
accepted this like six months ago I
guess we leave so nearly access last
month uh it's kind of you ever you
remember the movie from the 80s called
Maximum Overdrive you take a look like
there's this thing about alien signal
machines to story everything right you
can kind of like uh you could take over
like a light post and like change if it
was uh red or green and yes Austin havoc
that way there was a scene where the
vending machine gets taken over and
start shooting pop cans yeah so I
thought like that should be a game I
want to make that game so that's why
kinda well you your people might be they
might recognize you guys you guys make a
lot of like alien or space tech games
and games completely different visually
like if we even just go into the menu
screen I mean I've never seen you guys
make a game of this style before and
it's really exciting to see you guys
branched out into this very strange
almost like a 3d comical universe yeah I
think it kind of needs to be comical
otherwise it would just be very violent
well it's a really comical game because
you you in it it's a violent game
because you guys are basically a will
the one that I played you had to kill 10
dudes in three minutes yeah that's the
stuff like that I think that's what
we're playing oh it's 15 and you do that
by taking over devices cars fire
hydrants all sorts of whatever you can
do to kill people and you kind of here
we go yeah you like uh there's
essentially you're kind of like this
weird alien gods
can take over any machine and then so
it's really fun game develops like
honestly have no idea of like oh I want
to make some giant ball that you can
take over to destroy the city with so I
can just add that in and then it just
that all the levels are animal generated
Mike hilarious and I also just love
making disruption physics like that is
my favorite thing so making it so
building can like the destroyer piece by
piece then falls down and it splits into
that that's essentially why I made this
game well it's like every kid's dream to
be able to absolutely destroy a city
with random objects and whatever you
deem necessary you know who you're
supposed to kill cuz you're just killing
randomly are you know oh yeah I do have
like I do have an objective right now
but so far I've just been killing people
killing people you could also take over
bridges only love the ability to take
over like mundane stuff I haven't added
taking over a signpost yet to stuff my
back so I don't think what you would do
but she's a little monster truck yeah
it's really neat to so when you're not
Manning anything your controls are
basically moving around the camera in
the world but once you like are in a car
the same controls are used to drive
reverse yeah steer your vehicle so it
does like oh you just exploded your own
car there and now there's a guy where'd
you get that robot oh there's all these
like secret things you can unlock you
just have a robot don't know where these
guys will grab it again because there's
a guy really high in the building
there's like a tall building right yeah
oh yeah so there's some of those guys or
I guess you'd fly and you have to find a
way to get to these people high in these
buildings and kill them yeah I can't
wanted a reason to destroy his stuff so
like if there's a guy in the building
you can't just you have to like take off
all the support beams and we have to
grow up how to get him down
there's a vending machine they can't see
anything I'll get that guy sitting up
yeah get him this is gonna take forever
you from destroying this entire building
projects those cams are really strong
come on yeah die okay I can't give up
two kids okay nevermind i can move on oh
wait there's no no one look sighs yeah i
did see you again nice it's a nice
little a pool of blood to justify that
he's dead but i thought i did one where
i took over a fire hydrant kinda like
sprayed water at people I mean there's
all sorts of stuff that you can mess
with there's a helicopter over there
although I think those are pretty hard
to control I mean that's kind of
intentional yeah GTA mix helicopter
patrols really easy and you're not
supposed to crash in this I don't really
care if the player crashes like it's
supposed to be kind of like that wait if
it's challenging to control it then it's
a really good thing to take out the guys
in buildings you really feel like you're
good at the game and you can direct
yourself look bad to take out the top of
the building but yeah right now this is
two minutes like you just have to
destroy as much stuff can get as much
guys in two minutes this gives if his
last longer than two minutes then you
destroyed everything and there's not
much to do right that point but other
than dove modes are there besides killed
15 dudes in a couple minutes ah those
three modes there's that one and then
arcade where it's kind of destroy
everything get points for that and then
another one called Zen which is kind of
destroy everything no points take as
long as you want but this G bone thing
is still my favorite one one thing I
want to find there's a car that I made
it's pretty much a direct ripoff of
rocket League I really want to find that
at least you're honest yeah it was
essentially oh there it is Parker weaker
called the rocket car but you can have
boost yeah turn uh yeah I think more
games should just do the rocket League
controls because it's so fun and this is
the best to take our guys eat open book
can really like snipe them when they
made a rocket-powered battle car it
wasn't for that reason it was only for
sport her desolate never meant to be
driven in the city I want to see like
combat games cuz I Dracula controls like
that where am I going oh you've a little
map there too you can pull up full
screens if you're really trying to give
my many points as possible you get it I
quickly take out the guys but I think
I'm more just driving around Detroit
stuff right whatever like just city's
destruction is there any a bonus to
actually just ruining as much as you can
of the city yeah it in the different run
the arcade mode you can know it's just
about destroying the more stuff you get
points for that this is an alien thing
that can suck up stuff
silly it's just like at some point you
went with straight fun no no reality the
glutes make it is fun and silly as
possible that really comes across in
this yeah essentially this also a VR
version that were working on really a
giant monster taking over like the story
is really like a Godzilla yeah but
that's still in development that'll be a
while till dr actually makes sense yeah
what tools are you using with it are you
working on like with oculus or it's
gonna be 55 yeah yeah we were just
messing with the by the other week it's
just insane yeah actually think you did
a video on it yeah right always trying
to like mess with it in any way we can
we're like messing in the paint area so
rads like paint and B are so you can
pick up anything you want and then drop
it would you like pick up people in the
ocean oh no oh I think that building is
distorted behind him too so that's a
nightmare the nightmare scenario yeah I
got it wrecking ball
yeah I feel like we should have gotten
to the wrecking ball as soon as possible
it seems hard to control how do you good
wrecking ball yeah been around hope it's
a ball it's what you want pretty much
yeah um I think it's good that you can
make things too easy just want to take
out that last baby yeah I'd do it and
then get that helicopter and kill that
dude with the blades oh no oh my
nightmare run hey there he's so dead I
read this guy do it slow who are these
g-men what did they do I don't know
government men government clearly has
been a long time in the story of this
game hey you look at the evil covered
minute yes evil government that's how
you take it out well I mean it it's
absolutely ridiculous it's so much fun
and like how far along are you guys in
this um what else do you want to do
besides just add more silly things are
you gay like are you gonna add any more
modes are you guys gonna add a story or
you just like this is it this is what
you get we keep adding new levels and
stuff we always have new ideas like this
recently added a tornado and that was
really fun I don't know how it makes
sense you take over a tornado but it's
fun there does matter it makes sense i
mean but i guess it doesn't make sense
in the in your world because it's not
like electronical but at the same time
you don't give a [ __ ] so you just can
make something you make sense it's like
a tornado machine you take over
something got a tornado machine because
humans made that because we're meant
exactly and then for some reason it's in
the middle of a city don't worry the top
scientists are working on our tornado
machine nothing will go wrong ever it's
going to work out there's there's going
to be no repercussions for this tornado
machine invest yes exactly well this is
absolutely Philly kill one more dude
listen today all right they get to be
the tank but I think that's one of the
last ones here
this one's a little bit too easy just
shooting missiles at everything no dad
oh my god it's absolute pandemonium it's
just like a fun kids playground honestly
as what you made yeah I like it for
events that something pick-up-and-play I
don't have to sit there and describe the
game like i usually do with our games
that's right it's easier on you did you
make this specifically so that you could
not try an event that and making
destruction sizzix see leave okay set
you guys that was maximum override it's
such a fun and silly game thank you so
much for showing me that Lee yeah and
then where can people pick this up it's
on Steam early access and then yeah I
don't know besides that I haven't
figured that ever so I'll to come it's
all a mystery and would look finding it
out but you guys can get it an early
access at least on Steam how much is it
uh seven bucks seven bucks yeah that's
sweet so thank you guys so much
you